how big of a deal was it because i know
you know when nipsey died it just it
really [ __ ] man it [ __ ] me up i'm no
nip for
since 09 and um you know but
when he passed away um big u had kind of
helped
put together that day of unification
where everybody
can't pulled up you know on on that
intersection and
and it was like it was it was i didn't
realize the uh
significance of how big of a deal it was
that a lot of those people were
in the same place in a peaceful manner
because a lot of a lot of neighborhoods
beef and have been beefing
for decades like and i i put it to the
[ __ ] analysis of the hatfields
and the mccoys
right you go you got [ __ ] who was
beefing before you was even born
so it's that tradition of beefing and
it's just like
damn yeah i was standing in the same
spot as them [ __ ]
y'all been killing them [ __ ] for
decades you get me
and vice versa so
that basically nip's passing sort of
represented
trying to unify
[ __ ] on the aspect of not just are you
from over here i'm from over here
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you you know it kind of
it kind of led to the to the place of
trying to
show that [ __ ] don't have to
kill [ __ ] just over [ __ ] i get it
y'all represent there we represent here
but this was a dude who
basically tried to [ __ ] with everybody
whether it was [ __ ] whether it was blood
whether you was from the enemy
neighborhood from 15 years ago or
whether whatever
i tried to [ __ ] with everyone so that's
to me what that represent as far as big
you and nipping them and him passing
and everybody trying to show unification
together it was to show that
the outside world sees us just vicious
[ __ ] gang-banging ass vicious
drive-by killing [ __ ]
and it's bigger than that or it's what
is beyond that
so coming together shows people
that these [ __ ] that y'all look
at as these vicious [ __ ]
can can set aside their beasts from long
standing and
some [ __ ] might not even know why we
beef you get me
i just started gang banging and i know
we hate them [ __ ] over there right
right right i'm not old enough to know
what we believe in about
but all i know is the minute i start
claiming over here we cross out them
[ __ ] and we say [ __ ] them
and the funny thing about it is six
years ago
i was in the same class as that
[ __ ] i think we was playing
kickball together
outside and whatever so it just showed
that we can set aside [ __ ]
for a mother for for my [ __ ] who
was already on that aspect like i got i
know where i'm from
but i got no problem with you my [ __ ]
if you ain't got no problem with me i
understand what happened back then
and i would never live that [ __ ] down
and i will always
know where i come from but [ __ ]
if you want to get me on the song
your blood hell yeah let's do it right
you want me
you want to beat from me or want me to
come to your video or we know how to get
money
or we can do this together man that's
going to be better for you and me in the
long run
you get me